Morticia and Gomez are one of the
spookiest couples in pop culture
history — so why are fans up in arms
about their portrayal in Wednesday?
Tim Burton's Wednesday has finally arrived on
Netflix, and in a snap (or two for the fans
out there), it has been snatched up by eager
audiences who have binged through this new
take on the Addams Family's dark-minded daughter.
In particular, fans have praised Jenna Ortega's
performance as Wednesday Addams. In the new
series, Wednesday takes center stage after
being enrolled in Nevermore Academy, where she
begins investigating a series of brutal murders.
Obviously, it wasn't exactly what you'd call a
shocking revelation to see Wednesday getting the
most attention out of the Addams family we know,
love, and fear — the show is named after her,
after all. Still, would it really be
an Addams-adjacent project if the other
members of the titular family didn't
make an appearance? For some, though,
therein lies the problem. Now that viewers have
finished with the first season of Wednesday,
it seems that some are taking issue with
the heads of the Addams family household.
"I've always been open to constructive criticism."
In the show, Morticia and Gomez are played
by Catherine Zeta-Jones and Luis Guzmán,
who, while having nowhere near
as much screen time as Ortega,
still had some serious shoes to fill. The roles
have been irrevocably bound to Anjelica Huston
and Raúl Juliá since they brought the characters
to the big screen with flawless chemistry in Barry
Sonnenfeld's 1991 film The Addams Family
and its 1993 sequel, Addams Family Values.
"I would die for her. I would kill
for her. Either way, what bliss."
It may be that these rock-solid performances
still linger in the minds of fans,
since some viewers have claimed that
they fail to see even a flicker of
a spark between Morticia and Gomez
in this new take on the characters.
If you're familiar with cartoonist Charles Addams'
original characters, you'll know that Morticia and
Gomez Addams more than look the part on Wednesday,
with Guzmán's short stature providing a humorous
contrast to Zeta-Jones' height. However, looks
aren't everything, and some fans seem to feel that
romance is very much dead between the two — which
is unfortunate, since the Raul Julia and Anjelica
Huston incarnations of the characters are depicted
as such lovebirds. In the television subreddit,
one fan expressed their concerns about
the characters' casting. They wrote:
Another Redditor agreed, saying:
But if the final choices weren't up to snuff
for audiences, who else would fit the bill
for one of pop culture's maddest
couples? One Reddit user suggests:
Still, if a second season of
Wednesday gets the green light,
Zeta-Jones and Luis Guzmán might get another
shot to capture the passion that some believe
has been missing this time around. Everyone
is allowed to have one bad day, after all.